hello in this video we'll talk about
syphilis
so what is syphilis
it's a bacterial infection which is
spread
by sexual contact so it's a sexually
transmitted disease and the causal
organism behind syphilis is triponima
pallidum
triponima pallidum
is a spirochete so what is a spirochete
so spirochete are those bacteria which
have long helically coiled corkscrew
like appearance
they are mainly gram-negative bacteria
and they contains distinct diderm or
double membrane
and they're about like three to five
hundred micron longer and
they have endo flagella system that
means flagella within the bacteria and
this endoflagella help this bacteria to
make a corkscrew like motion and this
corkscrew like motion helps the bacteria
to wade through the thick mucus and
invade the cells of the host
so generally it is acquired by sexual
contact
but whenever these bacteria find any
bridges in the squamous or columnar
epithelium they make their way inside
and that is how it is transmitted
so let's look at what does syphilis
infection look like what are the stages
so syphilis infection can be a
subdivided into four stages and all
these stages has different timelines
so the primary stage occurs within the
three to
ninety days of infection
and there are distinct
symptoms
by which we can identify this particular
stage
there is a secondary stage
which is about four to ten weeks after
infection there is a latent stage where
there is no symptoms and there could be
a tertiary stage if untreated it would
be visible after 3 to 15 years of
infection
so
let's take couple of minutes to
understand these phases of
infection in bit more details
so first we begin with the primary
syphilis or the primary stages of
syphilis
in this case there would be source
in the site of infection
generally this can be found on external
genitalia that means penis and in vagina
so
these source are known as shanker
generally they are painless so they go
unnoticed
[Music]
now if we zoom into the shanker we can
see it has a raised border hard base and
a fluid filled substance which is kind
of
uh hosting a lot of triponima uh
bacteria and whenever there is a touch
in this particular shanker there could
be spread of
the troponium bacteria
so this source can occur in genitals
anise
and in or around the mouth
and generally it has a lot of syphilis
bacteria inside it
now let's say accidentally during sex
a person has touched the penis which has
a shanker on that
so suddenly
some of these uh
syphilis
causing triponima bacteria can possibly
invade through the small bridges inside
the skin and possibly can infect you
now the secondary
stage of syphilis is bit more
complicated the symptoms include rashes
swallowing lymph node
and also systemic responses like fever
so the triponima
moves to the lymph node and then
eventually it moves to the bloodstream
this is known as acquired syphilis
but if syphilis is acquired through
blood transfusion
then this kind of primary phase is
completely not there
so directly civilized can be found in
the bloodstream shankara development
would not take place
now during the secondary stage of
syphilis there is generalized
lymphadenopathy that means swallowing
lymph node which is visible throughout
the body and not only in the site of
infection
so in that
stage
the bacteria is infecting the blood
vessels capillary and especially the
capillary endothelial cells
now triponima attaches to the capillary
endothelial cell surfaces and infect
them
and that results in rashes all around
the body and this is known as macular
papular rash which is generally not
itchy but reddish in appearance
now there could be different type of
rashes some are postular which is filled
with pus
some are papulosquamas which are scaly
or hard rashes some of them are known as
condylomalata which are small whitish
bumps on the skin all these rashes are
visible
or some of them are visible during the
secondary stage of syphilis and this
generally occurs 6 to 12 weeks from the
infection
so this stage is highly infectious even
even if you touch these rashes there
could be a transmission of the syphilis
causing organism to you
during the latent stage there are no
obvious signs and symptom
so in this stage
the number of bacteria is also less
there are few bacteria but that might
cause serious complication
they can attract immune system for
example they can activate t helper cells
especially especially the th1 subtype
which can lead to type 4
hypersensitivity response eventually it
secretes bunch of inflammatory cytokines
pro-inflammatory cytokines such as
interleukin-1 6 and tnf alpha
which further activates macrophages and
these activated macrophages can lead to
variety of responses involving swelling
redness warmth in the local region and
can also lead to systemic responses
which ultimately lead to fever
now
a goma is formed in case of tertiary
syphilis
tertiary syphilis happens like after
even after years of the infection
agoma is basically a clump of dead
immune cells
so
in this case you can see immune cells
fibroblasts all of them
attached together forming a clamp
which has a necrotic core
and this goma appears on the skin liver
or even in the bones
so in the tertiary syphilis what really
happens is there could be development of
granulomatous granulomatous lesions in
your liver bone or even in the skin
there could be onset of cardiovascular
lesions which known as which is known as
cardiovascular syphilis there could be
neuropathy which is associated with
tertiary stages of the syphilis known as
neurosyphilis and there could be also uh
several other manifestations such as the
the testis and the intestine that could
have serious consequences but not
summarized here
now the question is how syphilis is
diagnosed
so triponima pallidum cannot be seen in
gram staining so obviously a dark field
examination is critical for the
detection that's a
kind of screening test
also triponima pallidum can be detected
by silver nitrate staining in a
otherwise yellowish background the
bacteria will look like black
now there are serological tests which
are a bit more sensitive and
confirmatory
one such test is
tppa or triponium palladium particle
agglutination test already a mouthful
but it's a very simple test in this case
in a microtiter plate
you take a avon
rbc which is coated with
triponimapillidium antigens
and then you
introduce patient serum sample which
might or might not have antibodies
against triponema
if there is antibody against triponema
there would be precipitation of the
rbcs there would be agglutination if
there is no
antibodies there would be no
agglutination
and
we can check
for these samples for agglutination
this is a hypothetical test result here
you can see
how a positive and a negative result
look like so in this spectrum
your your sample might fall in somewhere
in this spectrum there are alternative
sensitive tests against triponema
pallidum such as fluorescence triponim
antibody absorbed test
here fluorescently labeled antibodies
against
specific triponima antigens are used for
detection
now let's look at the treatment option
as this is a bacterial infection
antibiotics are proper
for treatment
now obviously you should go and consult
a doctor if you think you have
syphilis
now syphilis
can
syphilis can be transmitted from mother
to baby and this is known as congenital
syphilis
the triponima can actually pass through
the
placenta and can infect the baby
that is why it is important during
pregnancy you might do a syphilis test
now if the baby is born with congenital
syphilis there could be several
complications including maculopapular
rash in the feet and in the palms there
could be hearing defects
optic
neuritis there could be satellites
hutchinson teeth and many other
characteristic features which are found
in congenital syphilis so it can lead to
many complications in a newborn
so i hope this video kind of summarizes
all the necessary points regarding
syphilis the pathophysiology of it the
microbiology and how we can detect
syphilis
notes are available in my facebook page
you can follow my facebook page
and the link is provided in the
description as usual don't forget to
like share and subscribe do let me know
how you like this video in the comment
section you can support my channel in
patreon i'm presenting a wide variety of
social media all the links are provided
in the description my courses are also
present in
academy you can use my code ap10 to get
an in-person discount see you in next
video thank you